it was one of those songs which we went
through hell torture to bring that kind
of experience out from actors
how does it feel to add Academy Award
nominee to your list of accolades what
else could an actor ask for what else
would a filmmaking ask for to be a part
of the biggest celebration of Cinema
globally the Oscars I mean we are I
wouldn't say nervous but I'm just I'm
just waiting for it to happen you know
it's just every day day by day I'm just
waiting for it to for that day we're
gonna walk the carpet I Think We're not
gonna walk as actors of RR or actor as
I'm not going to walk like an actor of
from the Indian film industry I'm going
to walk as an Indian on that carpet with
pride filled in my heart carrying my
nation in my heart what was that moment
like because not too Natsu dropped
people started loving it before the
movie even came out was there at this
moment where you were like this film is
crossing all of these Global lines
everyone loves it we had no idea when RR
released RR literally crashed into the
West which like to come my place for a
coffee before I drop you home
inviting you home for a coffee
so Oscars are on Sunday who do you want
to meet is there anyone you want to pick
their brain everybody people are going
to be coming after you it's going to be
a surreal experience you know everyone
every actor
I have experienced growing as an actor
everybody has etched something in my
mind to become a better actor I just
want to looking forward to to see
everybody they're going to be my
favorite filmmakers they're going to be
seniors they're going to be actors of my
generation you know I think Oscars is
like it's like a kid in a candy shop and
I'm gonna be a kid there I'm gonna keep
watching for everybody I like everyone I
love everyone I saw growing up just
can't wait for it to happen who are you
bringing do you know what you're wearing
see I'm I'm going to represent India so
I'm going to wear something Indian oh
well that's a surprise I'm gonna hold on
to what the surprise is going to be okay
hopefully you get to see it on the
carpet I'm having something from India
which I want to showcase so I'm going to
be dressed in Indian I wanted to bring
my wife you know we were at the Globes
last time why aren't you breaking her
you know unfortunately my kids missed
their school for a month okay and now
it's her turn to you know stay back to
them or she would have loved it she
would have really loved being a part of
her Oscars but unfortunately she had to
stay back to take care of the kids but
she went to the Globes yes she was where
you won oh yeah we won not to not to
[Music]
a lot of people including myself think
that RR should have gotten more
nominations this whole award season but
especially by the academy do you uh
let me tell you this I'm not sounding or
I'm not trying to be diplomatic about it
but for an Indian film getting a
nomination is something which is great
and natural I think it was one of those
songs which we went through hell torture
to bring that kind of experience out
from actors so I think I'm happy with
natimato I'm happy with my nomination
for NATO NATO
the whole team is elated for for the
kind of
struggle strain we've been through for
that song I'm happy with it tell me
about that process because it's I mean
one of the most joyous things is when
you guys have the suspenders and you're
doing the little Shuffle was there a
part that was particularly hard to get
down because Raja mali's going frame by
frame and going up your arm is over here
you need to redo it yeah he was having
the step freeze going on you know every
time we were shooting every time there
was a take he was like no you know what
your legs need to be a little more in
sync I was like you know what that
doesn't happen we have different styles
you know we are different you know each
person has a different style of dancing
so but for him it was so important that
in the film when two friends are alike
when they align together you really
don't need to look at each other you
know that you're one yes so RR is about
friendship it's it's celebrating
friendship that's friendship ouch
talking about the the experience of
shooting for that song you know I've
been telling this my legs still hurt my
legs I mean I like it on round shoulders
it was I mean it the steps as such were
not hard but what was harder is the sink
we were practicing it every day for
three hours we were rehearsing every day
while shooting for that song we
rehearsed a week before we shot for that
song and we were rehearsing on set as
well it's only for the synchronization
and I was like you know I know rajmoli
for a long time and this is my fourth
collaboration with him I knew him for 20
years now and I was like I did I know
he's a he's a hard filmmaker but I was
like I was surprised I was like why is
he picking on this so much you know why
is he talking about the sink but when
the promo of the song was released back
in India before the film released here
or before it was a sensation here in the
West
people were talking about nothing but
the synchronization yeah I was like
ouch I'm like how do you know for me it
was it was like a surprise now how do
you know the pulse of the audience is
how I don't know how he does it but oh
my God I can't imagine like working with
him you get the script or whatever and
he's like I'm gonna do this today like
we're gonna flip you upside down and
you're just like okay
you don't have a choice yeah you really
don't have a choice of a bridge and
you're gonna hold him yeah we had that
we had that pendulum swing and that was
I think the third day of the shoot when
we started off that was the third day
and I just remember you know I hate
roller coasters I just can't get on
roller coasters my sons love them but
the moment he just dropped me from 60
feet high up there I had butterflies in
my stomach I was screaming I was like
stop it I don't want to do it but I
think rajmali also mentioned it all the
stunts which we did in the movie except
for if I would say two or three shots
there was no head replacement at all
there was no dupe at all it was us doing
those hardcore stuff please
yes you could be a part of any franchise
you wanted what would you want is there
anything that you would like like Ronald
is like Tom Cruise who I've been growing
up watching I want to work with him
under his production whatever let him
direct me Marvel yeah Marvel for me is
there a character because I would love
to do you know I I said this Iron Man is
by far my favorite only for a reason
that you don't need to because I don't
know I feel this you don't need to come
from a separate planet or you don't need
to be an alien as such coming from
another planet you don't need to be a
part of a laboratory experiment or you
don't need to be a Demi God or a God you
are me yeah Iron Man to me represents me
the human beings we are yep you know the
the knowledge we gained I think that's
our man for me yeah so I wonder I would
love to be an Iron Man is my favorite
Iron Man Raj Mali talked about rr2 which
I think was a surprise maybe it's you
guys we never heard of it before have
you talked to him since is there
something you would love to see in a
sequel I would love rr2 why not you know
when it's got the potential why not when
the now that we have the West also
waiting for it now we have the globe
waiting for rr2 I said why not but he
still hasn't discussed with us about it
I'm just waiting if he can actually
start discussing now before the Oscars
happen this is the franchise I want I
also love why it's called RR I learned
this recently yeah it's it's our names
it's just your name it's just not names
it was it was just on social media when
he just he still didn't announce the
movie there was a quirky wink which he
which he tweeted it was just me children
and and he's called Ram Charan I'm in t
Rama Rao Junior so R from that Rama Rao
and are from rajamouli just started from
there and it just became a rage and
you know sometimes I just feel like you
just don't need to actually name a movie
yeah you know when sometimes a movie
just becomes a brand by itself the first
thing you say just sticks absolutely
yeah
[Music]